kimi's wife filed for divorce
she goes to get half his money turns out
it's filed under his mom fantastic yeah
fantastic so there's this guy who plays
for uh was it Real Madrid and then
Morocco or PSG and um how he grew up in
Spain I think so yeah yeah and
um and we we obviously went to Morocco
and you know we're like all into it
that's where I first kind of really
heard about this dude and um just an
amazing story I don't know if this is
real but it's going viral everywhere
yeah apparently oh it's 100 meal also
this won't be like
like this will just be a tax Dodge so
he's like oh uh this I pay my wages to
her kiwi football limited and my mum is
the CEO of it and it'll be so he's not
it'll be like the way taxes work in
Europe is if you do that you'll pay a
lot less tax on the money if it's get
paid to a business rather than an
individual because you can get more tax
breaks so it will be that like it's very
common like for comedians who start
start earning a lot of money in the UK
like their partners are then like
managing director of Andrew Schultz
comedian yeah yeah
okay let's look at her so she's of
Tunisian descent born in Spain as well
um from Spain is like big and then
apparently there's reports that he's
gonna get half of her assets yeah
because she's got money yeah her assets
are in her name you never once thought
about where the money's coming from yeah
you never once were like hey whose name
is this oh you don't have anything in
your name yeah in years of marriage it
never came up it was never mentioned but
like it's so easy to explain like if she
goes where's this when you come from he
goes oh it's coming from this shelf
company so we don't have to pay taxes
yeah it's in modern she doesn't know she
doesn't [__] understand what it is
yeah also this is how you know that
everybody's acting like she's some gold
digger like this I know you know she was
pure she never asked where the money was
gone yeah she actually loved him had
kids with him like this isn't some gold
digger she put two kids out here yeah
and he's gonna take half of her [__]
that's some scumbag [__] if you ask me
is it a big like bad breakup like why is
the news of the whole money there's some
infidelity going on I assume his
infidelity is because he's a soccer
player and that's apparently just what
it is
you probably can't like you probably the
word allegedly but there's
rumors and uh proceedings I believe that
the infidelity was not consensual as
well whoa oh that was an allegation
there's allegations and what apparently
what you said is that's what for like it
was too far
which is allegations which I don't know
it's kind of great timing yeah oh okay
allegedly she's like not only have you
she's done me you've raped someone and
ah gosh that's the that's the
allegations
yeah the players well out there bro yeah
we just hearing about the money
situation
yeah nothing about that he said why is
everybody on the take or something like
that like why does the or why why are we
not getting that information because
everybody knows out there in Europe yeah
like I I knew that before and I knew the
divorcing but like I could list you a
load of footballers there's rumors about
and allegations like Cristiano Ronaldo
can't play in the states there's a
reason he went to Saudi Arabia I won't
say what that reason is oh well we all
know that oh I didn't realize it was due
though but I thought they dropped that
case
they dropped the case because he paid
her
but there's transcripts of him go
there's a transcripts of Ronaldo you
could find it in five seconds yeah where
he's like she repeatedly asked me to
stop and I carried on yeah holy [__]
yeah like he's confessed it but he was
like here's the money but then she came
back and asked for more money and it was
like no Kobe doesn't have one as crazy
as that but Kobe got a wild one Kobe got
one where he basically is like I
understand why she thought it was rape
like Kobe got a wild one too
so I know it sounds crazy I know but
it's so we also went through the trial
and then so the public opinion it's
easier to digest it because it's like
well he was found not guilty so he's not
guilty you see what I'm saying this is I
said she asked me to stop and then I
just paid her off and everybody's
overlooking that he's saying he plays
for Arsenal
um and so it's also common knowledge
that there's stuff going on with him but
he's just being allowed to continue to
play because it's not he hasn't been
charged with anything yeah so his name's
Thomas party he also plays for Ghana
but like
when arsenal when he scores for Arsenal
he also has like [__] getting party
if you look at any quote tweets of it
it's are you really celebrating this one
well there was one guy that had
allegations got dropped from every team
and then the allegations were false or
something and then didn't get resigned
do you remember this I forget what this
was this was like something recent
English Guy Mason Greenwood I think so
yeah no so that wasn't false so Mason
green month
um there's there's uh audio footage that
his now pregnant partner
uh it was like leaked and she was like
oh I didn't put that out there but it's
she's because he was abusing her like
she's not crazy and like she's audio
recorded it to have as evidence and
she's like Mason stop and he's like I
want to have sexual issues like well I
don't want him and he's like I don't
give a [__] what you want cheese oh my
God so he he was dropped by his place
for Manchester United and he still
listed as their thing because it was
going to court a witness dropped out she
didn't want to press charges anymore
because apparently she's pregnant with
this child whoa and she was like look
yeah it's a really horrible toxic
relationship but I want to be back with
you so he's now not going to prison
because there's no charges to be
followed up on I didn't realize but
there's audio that you again could find
in 30 seconds on the internet of him
doing that stuff but she's like I love
him I wanna so then what do you do but
then no Manchester United fan ever wants
him to play for Manchester United yeah
there's some [__] idiots on Twitter
who are like I'll just get him back you
know he's not guilty it's like no he he
hasn't been found guilty that doesn't
mean he hasn't done anything uh can you
really then put him in a [__]
Manchester United chairs and have
children around the world yeah [__]
worshiping this guy when there's
literally audio footage on the Internet
is this a newer thing soccer players is
no good yeah
dude these guys are good Americans yeah
because we had this for football players
in America right like this kind of
sounds similar but we have the excuse of
you know they just are riddled with CTE
yeah I think I I think social media has
just made it easier for people like me
to find out that it happened like this
has always been happening you're saying
I think so like the reason I know the
rumors about Thomas party is that it was
all over Twitter and the girl who was
involved was like the police aren't
doing anything here to literally
screenshots of the text from me and him
Jesus
um so she was like nothing's gonna
happen to him but I want you all to know
who this guy is
um I would never you would never have
heard about that in the 90s if a
footballer was accused of it like
like our soccer players are just so used
to people like faking being hurt
I thought she was trying to draw yellow
and play The Whistle no it's a wild
thing that that news never comes over
here I mean we do get soccer news like
this uh Hakimi story is just nuclear
everybody's talking about it but I think
that's more like manosphere stuff yeah
yeah that's what that's why you know
that's not he could be working in
[__] doesn't mean it's like uh
Britney's ex what was his name Kevin
yeah when he got that settlement yeah
that's the most story of all time yeah I
think Kelly Clarkson's husband got a
bunch of money from her I didn't like
that though wait what I don't know why I
kind of I like Kelly Clarkson I like
that
she's so sweet yeah she's just sweet she
seems like a nice hard-working girl
yeah you know what I mean she doesn't
seem like a gold digging [__]
right like she made all the money yeah
no I don't know I hope she is such a
nice comments
yeah good for you [__] done good for
yourself yeah yeah you know who Kelly
Clarkson is yeah okay you're not a
musician